what's the purpose of life what's it all
about what are we doing on this planet
that's the theme of this talk show and
we bring on people
who found their way in life people who
have been really contemplating and
thinking about these really important
questions
so we've got one of those we're going to
call him an original american
anglo-saxon
irish background he's here on the dean's
show
my brother and your brother phil we also
got some celebrity
news for you oscar de la hoya
and some of the other famous celebrities
will be talking about him here on the
show don't go anywhere we'll be right
back with this exciting episode
[Music]
this is
[Music]
this is
and now you call the original american
anglo-saxon
yeah well you yes you have been the
first to turn me the anglo-saxon
american but yeah so your family goes
all the way back to the may the what's
that called the i think the mayflower in
the pilgrims
came off yeah so uh yeah supposedly
my grandfather did the family tree a
long time ago and supposedly goes back
all the way to uh mayflower so we got
rock all that type of stuff we got an
original american here on the
dean's show and also your mother's irish
yes what part of art have you been back
there i have not been to ireland
i have not okay so now you became a
muslim
i did you found your way in life purpose
of life you asked those tough questions
to yourself subconsciously you're just
thinking
you know pondering so we're going to go
a little bit way back in history
yeah talk about a little bit of your
past sure
tell us a little about yourself um
well i grew up massachusetts so i am a
red sox fan patriots fan
we kind of have to you know have to be
those fans i grew up in massachusetts
went to high school
in north andover mass ended up at
colorado state university
and at that time if we want to get you
know cut to the subject
real quick about how i became muslim i
remember
towards the end of my college career
really battling with
you know why are we here um or why am i
even
like on campus at this time why am i
even in college and most of that comes
from
where and i would say 80 to 90 percent
of the college students nowadays are in
college because they have to be
like if you're not if you don't go to
college after high school
you're almost like deemed like a loser
or like you weren't smart enough
or whatever it is and um and i think a
lot of the college kids go to college
because they have to
and obviously you know and we spend a
lot of money going to college even and
i'm walking across campus
thinking about why i'm you know why am i
here and i'm here if i if i don't go to
college
then i'm not i guess good enough and now
that i'm in college why am i in college
i have to go to college to get a degree
if i don't get a college degree i can't
buy a car
or make payments on a car or i can't get
a job to make payments on a car
i can't buy a house i can't have a
family and you have this kind of
reasoning for being in college that's
maybe the typical undeclared
you know undeclared major college kid
that was me
so i think subconsciously that can eat
away at people
um and you have kind of this like
shallow reason for being in college
and when you have that you cram for
tests
you do what it takes to get through and
then what do you do on the weekend you
go party with your friends
you have a good time a lot of times
those people get in trouble
and in reality i think that starts to
wear down on you
and at least it was wearing down on me
because that's really not a real
healthy high character high value
way of existence so at that time
i remember having to take a free
elective in college and i remember
opening up the course catalog
my junior year and pointing down at a
course just kind of like you know like
abacadaba
i'm going to take that course and the
course was muhammad and the origins of
islam
muhammad and the origins of islam right
so you know the first homework
assignment
you know non-muslim teacher just kind of
like an expert i guess on
the middle east medieval middle east
modern middle east
um first homework assignment was read
sort of bakura which is the longest
chapter in the quran
so i read that surah i had to read
some other you know like kind of like a
piece of paper maybe his senior thesis
or something on the difference between
sunni and shia muslims but regardless
i i started reading uh the quran at that
point
and i i could probably talk a lot
about um where it kind of led from there
um but let's just put it this way a lot
of my
um what i was thinking about life in my
direction where i needed to go
uh was quickly pointed and what i
thought was the right direction
regardless of whether i
thought the world existed a certain way
or however it was
uh all of a sudden right in front of me
was how what i believe is how the world
really is
now did you did you start to
when you when you opened up the quran
and you started reading it did you did
you the
things that the message that was being
couple couple things happened real quick
i think
a right away when you open up the quran
it very clearly says
do not say jesus is the son of god and
as a christian boy
growing up and i was a i would say
liberal christian boy because i believed
like a lot of kind of westernized
thought that you know i can come to god
on my own terms as long as i'm a good
person i don't do anything wrong to
anyone
um it's all good we're all going to go
to heaven
right and that can be very misleading
you know because you can think that
you're doing the right thing and you're
good as long as i do this you're fine
but
as you start to read the quran you find
out very quickly the quran is a lot
about the
community it's not just about yourself
it's not just about one person
and it's really about what we need to do
as a community
that's really the greater good um and
that's kind of just a
dive you know side topic but
jesus not being the son of god for
christian boy
that's the biggest thing that's the
biggest piece you have to wrestle with
do people really even think you know
what does that actually mean when they
talk about son of god people are
programmed and they just keep saying
something
son of god but if you if yeah and then
even in the quran it says
you know people it talks a lot about
being a product of
just where you were born and where you
grew up i mean we know that
following your forefathers yeah exactly
people who are ignorant who didn't know
and then they passed and i'm reading
that and i'm saying
yeah i am i'm i am a product of where i
grew up i mean
like even something like racism that's a
product of
society that's something that you grew
up when you came out of your mother's
womb you're pure you're this little
perfect baby and then as you get older
society starts impressing values upon
you
and that's where you get that junk from
yeah so i
it very quickly became me wanting to get
jesus right and i think
i'm muslim today because i got jesus
right
and what do you believe about jesus now
i believe jesus was
a prophet i believe he was born of the
virgin mary i believe
that he rose people from the dead
whether that was lazarus or not i know
that he prayed to god and he said god
raised this man from the dead
by the permission of god by the
permission of god by praying to god by
praying to the almighty
yeah you're all powerful they just
needed to say be and it was
and he was in the mother mary that makes
sense that makes sense doesn't it
it makes sense to me i mean it makes
sense to a lot of people who really just
use
their common sense yeah and he healed
the blind and you know and there are
some other things that you learn about
jesus from reading the crown that
um you know you may not know like he
spoke from the crib as a baby and he
defended
you know mary's chastity yeah so when
people when you read this
i mean it's not it's beautiful that you
see that you know
jesus and his mother are held at such a
high regard you know there's
many people don't know our brothers in
humanity that there's a chapter in the
quran the verbatim word of god
that's named after jesus's blessed
mother mary
america and you can actually go to the
hell fire if you don't believe in jesus
as a muslim is that right now did you
learn that
if you say i deny jesus yes i don't
believe that he did miracles i don't
believe he was a member or moses or
harrison or
abraham or ishmael or isaac that's deep
yeah man
it is so but did you find out anywhere
because of christian we got you know a
lot of christians out there
our brothers in humanity who we want the
best for one best for everybody
you know they'll say that look he said
he was god you know if you don't believe
in him did you go into the hell fire
you weren't full of the holy ghost have
you heard yes yes yes actually
absolutely and during the time i
remember a guy saying that he spoke in
tongues
and that he received you know
you know maybe the eucharist of christ
or whatever it was he said
but no absolutely and i guess my
question to everyone else would be is
what did jesus really say and what's
your proof
because i studied i became very addicted
and i really studied i really wanted to
get jesus right so i really was studying
where did the gospel get changed if you
study the medieval
middle east you start studying medieval
christianity and you see the power
struggle and you see how
i don't you know like where did worded
monks and priests and
priests not being able to get married
where did that all come from did jesus
say there shall be monks and don't get
married
no are you sure i mean i don't know that
was my question right i wanted to know
like yeah why are there
monasteries and why are there monks out
there and why are they not able to get
married because i don't remember jesus
ever saying that
but you know and that's just one little
tidbit or question so
so the fact is that jesus peace be upon
him never claimed he was god did you
find that about
that was clear he never ever explicitly
unequivocally
clearly loosely ever said i am god
worship me this is a statement that if
he was god
or the literal son of god he would have
had to have made saying i came to die
for your sins
did you ever find that in your invest in
your investigation looking for the truth
uh no i did not and i believe that that
can be arguably be so
from the bible as well i believe that
jesus even in the bible didn't say
i am god worship me and people argue
with that we can go back to john and
that's a much longer discussion
okay and that comes through translation
and all kinds of okay so we believe that
he was a mighty messenger of god did he
call people to worship the creator
not the creation we'll be right back
with more of phil's story here on the
dean show thank you
if you have a facebook guys i never ask
a man for help i ask a lot
have a facebook make sure you like our
statuses and think about deaf so i stay
in a sarah
you never know that one person that you
shared one of our videos to
and when no one's looking you sneak and
gives the cop you never know that person
might
change and end up becoming muslim and
you reap the rewards of everything that
person have learned has
learned from your share you rush to work
but you late for salah
a muslim never brags but his actions say
a lot like us
like facebook twitter and follow us on
twitter and one last thing
you want a piece of the prophet but not
peace for the prophet see that money is
your lord when you worship an object
go and subscribe if you have a youtube
subscriber
tab or quran you learn words to a song
subscribe
right now times by a thong you ain't
watching for shaytan you watch the
weight you put on
good i'll do it got my head on the
ground and my knees on the floor
and the devil in my ear eddie telling me
to trade it for the world
do it right now don't don't say tomorrow
do it now
islam is the truth and that's no
babies back here on the dean show with
phil
gave you a little nickname the original
anglo-saxon
your family goes all the way back to the
mayflower
flower lady at least a long time you got
some irish blood in your boy
yeah yeah yeah a long ways back it goes
a long way we're gonna do some
celebrity news i mean have you heard of
this irish actor liam neeson
what is the meaning the purpose of your
life you think
the purpose of my life yes
yes i have yeah i'm a fan of his movie
taken
i'm taking two i like it yeah liam
neeson in the uk son
newspapers reported that he said uh that
i'm i'm thinking of contemplating
becoming i'm thinking about becoming a
muslim you know he went to turkey to
film some show you know the story
yeah taken two so he actually while he
was and i heard this
there's interesting you bring that up
because he was um in turkey filming
taking two and i saw the movie
and it's very you know kind of like
typical like there's terrorists in the
movie
and you know they probably say like
allah
somewhere in the movie which really just
means god is great
and and he's the actor battling the
terrorists
right and this is all going on in the
movie it is i mean it's a good movie but
it's
you know embellished with the i don't
think it sheds a really great light on
muslims
like most of the movies that do that
what's interesting is off the scenes
he's contemplating becoming muslim
because he's in a muslim country and
he's seeing the beauty and the peace
of everything around him you know i
remember him saying he heard the call to
prayer
and he's seen people going back and
forth to pray
and uh i don't remember exactly a lot
you know a lot of god knows best what
exactly he said
but i remember reading that that was one
of the key things that he saw that
brought peace to him the question he's
talking about peace right he's talking
about peace and
we say islam means peace and people
always saying why wouldn't you know
islam means peace or
you know or like where does that come
from right but here's an example of a
person that actually felt that
he felt that now yeah from hearing the
call to prayer the
he was saying first it was starting and
it was annoying him in the beginning but
after a little bit of time
he started to feel that solace yeah and
he was one
he was he started ask questions that
many all of us should be asking what's
it all about you know what are we doing
on this planet why are we here
and did those thoughts ever go through
your mind before you accepted islam
absolutely they did because
like most kids at the time i was trying
to figure out why i was here what am i
going to do for life and am i doing
it for me am i doing it for someone else
and even if you are doing it for you
that can wear thin after time
and once you realize that really the
purpose of us
being here is to worship god and to do
his service
um but i don't think anyone else the
christian or someone else from another
religion
well that's the same thing that we
believe that we're here to you know
worship god we're worshiping god
always a tough question why don't you
just stay a christian well we got to get
it right
right if god if god doesn't approve of
what we're doing uh regardless of what
we really think we're doing it wrong and
and i don't think christians will
disagree with that anyone can get into
heaven without the forgiveness of god
and even
even muhammad some peace and frisbee
upon himself
knew that yeah i i i i i i go ahead
please continue so i mean it's important
to get it right
you know eve and but at the same time
even muslims will say
you're judged on your intention right um
so my intention was to get it right yeah
and i want to worship god the way
that makes him the most happiest and not
even say him say allah
because we don't want to say him because
he's not a man he's not a woman
has no gender yeah there's no god was
created in his image
created in his image means adam yes
so tell us now you know this concept
obviously of trinity
it just beguiles a lot of people it's
confusing
you know god is one in three three and
one and i mean no one just no one ever
took the uh water ice and gas
vapor or something like that that's how
they come to you with that yeah yeah no
absolutely
um no it doesn't make sense to me and i
think
even at the council of constantine and
you know the great chisholm and if you
study that back in history you know that
the trinity was officially made
a law back then um
and but and i think people got confused
i think people got confused you know um
uh because father son holy ghost right
so who's the father
well god our father who art in heaven do
you disagree with our father who are in
heaven not at all
okay we're talking about the creator
that's that's the creator of law exactly
yes
um holy ghost while muslims would refer
to the holy ghost
as gabriel or gabriel or the archangel
who came down to mary and told her that
she would be
pregnant and that she would have had not
slept with any man okay so
holy ghost um sun
i don't you know it really depends on
where you're going to go there with the
sun
peace but um definitely jesus is not the
sun but
you know what i mean yeah there's no son
of god there's no dividing god there's
no divine all he needs to do is say is
be and it is there's no
um look when you were studying now let's
let's just uh give a live example i got
three bibles here
okay you got the the du-ray version
that's the catholic this has seven that
was a little thicker
it's a little thicker okay then you have
the
king james version okay right in every
hotel room you could find one of these
this is
did you ever have one of these did you
know did you read something uh yep i've
seen that one okay and this is the in
1952
the rrsv now just to make a note this
has 66 books
so the point i want to drive home is if
you open this book
now this goes back to can i look at this
one yes please if i want you to
i want you just for our viewing audience
here if you could just open
open up the pentateuch right
no just right here i want you to when
you were when you started to study the
quran
and you see that there are aren't
countless versions of the quran if you
study the bible for instance this has 73
books
i don't want to dwell on this too much
this has 66 books so
you have seven whole books that were
thrown out so that's constitutes a
different version
and then this one that i just gave you
this rsv
if you read right here it says that the
king james version has what
grave grave defects that's hey
that's like you buying a car and a
you've got a recall for like 20 defects
on the car or plus
did you notice that now when you started
to study into it but then when you look
at the quran for instance
god's word can't have defects in it can
it
if it is literally god's word yes it
cannot have defects
i mean this was written by men we know
that this is a collection right
even if you have matthew mark luke and
john the gospel according to according
to
right um the thing about the quran and
the biggest
and you know i'll leave you with this is
the biggest thing for me is
if the quran is exactly what it says it
is
and this doesn't matter whether you're
muslim or not if the quran is what it
says it is the quran is literally the
word of god
delivered via gabriel to muhammad who
was an unlettered man who couldn't read
or write right and he was just told to
recite
right that was the first thing right
first thing he was told right
so if it is literally the word of god
then that's pretty important to me
and before i became muslim i said if
this is the word of god
then i'm gonna follow it because i'd be
stupid not to
but if it's any other thing i don't care
if it's a good book
i don't care if it's like a good message
i don't care if it's really close to the
bible i don't care if it makes your life
you live the best life at all
if it's anything other than exactly what
it claims it is
which is the little word of god then
it's unacceptable to me unacceptable
yes and many people don't know that that
things from
from these books they've been added
they've been adulterated
you can't i mean but there is good in
that there is truth in that there is
you're talking about the bible yes
because yes we know that we know that
the gospel was brought
muslims believe in the gospel we believe
in the ngo the original yes so what was
given to moses in its original was given
to jesus we believe in these things
there's even parts in the bible i think
it's deuteronomy 18 verse 10 or
something like that where it's
i mean muhammad is in the bible 18
economy 18 18 yes it talks about the
coming of the prophet muhammad peace be
upon him but the book's been changed so
we got to put it to the side with all
due respect
there is some of the word of god in here
but there are also anonymous books we
don't even know
but with the quran you found that it's
not like that
if you have a perfect message from god
what else do you need you got it
accepted brother
yeah so that's i mean that's if there
was one message that i had to send to
anyone it would be
read the quran and find out for yourself
that's right we got some uh some some
more
celebrity news to talk about we got to
finish up your story
yeah so we're going to take a break and
god willing
we'll be right back inshaallah sit right
tight we'll be right back with
philly phil the original anglo-saxon
here on the dean's show
i'm so tired when i read through the old
testament and new testament it didn't
make any sense
feels like i've walked
a thousand miles my
lies
[Music]
back here on the dean show with my
brother your brother
phil we just met i don't really know
anything about you i'm learning what
they're learning today
yeah your story is very interesting
that's why we have to have you on the
dean show
and we talked about a little bit about
your past
the time is short so we're kind of
getting a condensed version of your
story we're gonna bring people up to
speed on some current celebrity news
okay and put it in because it goes with
the theme of this talk show
and your story too i'm sure you can
connect it to i mean so
the the things we want to bring some
people up to to par on uh is um
you know amongst the celebrities amongst
the people that people look at to
for guidance a lot of the times because
they're looking at their style
you know what they're doing in life
their twitter they're trying to find the
dream we're all trying to live the dream
exactly but you know a few of them just
recent this this is happening you know
uh on a steady basis you got for
instance um
the disney star i don't know if you ever
heard of jackson
uh really famous she's a disney he was a
29 years old
suicide by gunshot oh man very rich very
famous
and next on the list you have
the gia alemen she's a reality tv star
okay
hung herself at the age of 29. all right
and let's go into our next
and last and we'll bring we'll get back
into your story celebrity news
what's going on oscar de la hoya now you
got to know oscar de la hoya
i've heard of that guy he plays
basketball right no he's a big-time
boxer he's the promoter that's promoting
the floyd mayweather fight he's golden
boy productions
he actually he admitted himself into a
into a rehab
and he was also we talked about a few
people that committed suicide he was
attac he was uh he admitted that he had
thoughts contemplating suicide admitted
he's an alcoholic on cocaine
this guy's worth 175 million dollars
he got paid 52 million plus endorsements
to fight floyd money mayweather
we did a show on to invite him to islam
he's 39 years old do you feel
that it that now you know you have this
peace
that obviously for a person to hang
themselves put a gun to their head
to be on coke dope alcohol they
obviously don't have peace and that's
something money can't buy do you feel
that you have
some craziness right now clearly money
can buy
happiness and that's what people are
trying to do they're trying to
find some sort of happiness or escape
the shallow reality
that the that we are
sometimes just lacking of accepting or
really understanding or just even waking
up i mean we're walking around in a
dream state half the time i can tell you
that the last week you don't remember
i mean how many days and moments of time
do we remember last week right
we really need to put purpose to our
life and people are trying to search
purpose and a lot of times they escape
that or they escape their lack of
purpose
um by doing drugs and all this other
stuff right
for right now what you have if someone
was to say look i'll give you that 175
million
anything i already i've already won the
mega bucks billion bucks trillion bucks
whatever it is if you gave me the entire
uh united states debt
dude i'm like one in there's you can't
one in a billion man i don't even i feel
so lucky
i'm so happy to have what i have i mean
it's so i know that i'm lucky i know
that what i have is so rare
it is it is very rare that you know like
you said anglo-saxon whatever
typical american white boy that grows up
and
has everything becomes muslim you know
marries another girl has six children
everything and you couldn't take it away
from me and i honestly believe this when
i first became muslim a lot of people
were like what was some of the things
that attracted you to islam and what
about the typical muslim service
honestly if you dropped me
from a helicopter anywhere in the world
in a parachute and i just
started going door-to-door and shaking
people's hands and say islam like them
like them sound like them i would
eventually find a muslim who will put
their arms around me drag me into their
house and feed me until i couldn't eat
anymore
and we're not even supposed to eat a lot
of food we're only supposed to eat until
you know we're not supposed to stuff
ourselves and go crazy and gorge
ourselves but that would happen
um so no man i'm the luckiest man in the
world and i've seen
i've seen poverty that you know just
from going on hydrogen being over in
saudi and stuff like that i've seen
poverty that's lower poverty than we see
and i see poverty in the united states
that's depression and i see poverty
in other countries where i've seen this
person is the poorest person in the
world
and you talk with them they got a big
smile on their face we got it we we
couple more questions yeah assuming
we're almost out of time uh
two two points for the people that that
tuned in and they're
they're listening and they're like they
need peace they're consummated purpose
of life someone even contemplated
suicide but now they tuned in
and and you know they realize you know
they might have had a lot of money they
lost it or they still have the money
they're not happy
maybe de la hoya is watching oscar de la
hoya it's possible you never know
nowadays
and and and now they want what you have
but they got some of these doubts in
their back in the head because why if
this is the truth
why is islam always being malign being
made to look like the terrorist religion
why is the media
find out for yourself man like you said
the media and i heard you say this
before like or somebody said this on
your show the media is a business right
you gotta if it bleeds it leads
um so you gotta find out for yourself
you gotta read the
you gotta read the quran it is literally
the word of god and i'll tell you it
answers all your questions
it does and you got to think about it
it's not about you
it's not about it's about serving god
and when the one thing that i've noticed
a lot is when you're
more selfless and you realize you're
serving other people
and you're serving a higher power very
quickly your problems become
very minuscule very business very
minuscule i mean
like forget the four celebrities how
about the
1500 people that just got gassed in
syria
or how about the couple thousand people
and anyone that has children out there
and you got little children can you
imagine coming home to that
serve that serve a higher purpose you
know what i mean um and that'll quickly
make all your problems seem very small
absolutely i wish we had more time we
gotta go peace out
thank you for being with us yeah thank
you may allah bless and we we
certainly expected the angels here in
this gathering and that allah has
blessed it
thank you amen now you could be similar
to oscar de la hoya many of us won't we
won't have that type of money
hundreds of millions of dollars you
could be sitting on gold and silver and
banks
bank accounts full with all of the money
but you can't buy peace you cannot buy a
six pack a piece you can't do it it
comes from the owner of peace the one
who created you created his whole
universe and everything in it
do the right thing right now ask the one
who who created you
the maker of mankind to guide you and
then start to do the legwork start to
look into islam
start to look into it we talked about
the verbatim of god the quran have you
read it look into it you've read every
other fashion magazine sports magazine
you've stayed up late at night watching
all the daytime nighttime dramas soap
operas
read this book to quran tune into the
deen show regularly
call us at 1-800-662-islam
and learn more i'm telling you learn
more this is a priceless
blessing a priceless gift and don't
forget
to visit us on facebook
you can go ahead and follow us there
like us there
on where we started a new hashtag
priceless blessings we want to get this
get the momentum here so we can be more
appreciated
for all the blessing that the creator
has given us so go ahead and like us
on facebook follow us on twitter and
don't forget to mention
that one price's blessing that comes to
your mind so we can be more grateful and
thankful
to the maker of mankind we'll see you
next time
peace be with you
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you